within hours of January 6th literally
hours you begin to hear that day
described as a deadly Insurrection not
described by one news Outlet or one
politician but in unison by all of them
almost like it was coordinated a deadly
Insurrection that's how history may
record January 6th but the tape that we
reviewed from within the building on
that day proves it was neither an
Insurrection nor deadly here it is
January 6th when an estimated 2000
rioters breached the Capitol Building
causing the deaths of five police
officers certain dates Echo throughout
history
December 7th 1941.
September 11 2001.
and January 6th the mob beat officers
with anything they had on them hockey
stick flagpole a fire extinguisher
police officers died Donald Trump
supporters who of course rioted and
killed police officers by the evening of
January 6 the Democratic party and its
publicist in the national news media had
settled on a description of what had
happened that day
they distilled an enormous number of
Highly Complex events events that even
now we don't fully understand into a
single emotionally related political
slogan which they've repeated for years
with remarkable discipline January 6
they said was a deadly Insurrection
there was a deadly Insurrection that the
right wing is trying to cover up he
incited a deadly Insurrection incited a
deadly Insurrection the violent deadly
Insurrection on the capitol nine months
ago it was about white supremacy in my
view a deadly Insurrection everything
about that phrase is a lie very little
about January 6 was organized or violent
surveillance video from inside the
capitol shows mostly peaceful chaos
but the slogan worked the term deadly
carries enormous emotional power which
is why they used it to prove the
Insurrection was deadly propagandists
pointed to the death of an officer
called Brian sicknick the mob killed
officer Brian sicknick that's what they
said it was their single most powerful
indictment of the January 6 protesters
and of Donald Trump and of Republican
voters nationally they repeated that
claim for years they are still repeating
it at first they told the country that
officer sicknick was murdered with a
fire extinguisher officer Brian cignac
died after being hit in the head with a
fire extinguisher during the fight that
story came from the New York Times which
is effectively the assignment editor for
most of the rest of American Media
it was a lie untrue in any way but only
after that lie had hardened into
conventional wisdom did the newspaper
bother to retract it the New York Times
has quietly retracted its story about
the death of Capitol Police Officer
Brian sicknick the damage had been done
Brian sicknick himself a trump voter had
been transformed without his consent
into a political murder of the left his
memory was shamelessly exploited by the
incoming Biden Administration in
February of 2021 cignic's body lay in
state in the capital rotunda were a
parade of unscrupulous politicians made
use of it here's Joe Biden breaking down
The Doors
trying to overturn an outcome of
election
and killing several police officers in
the meantime but Brian sicknick should
not be reduced to a prop for the
political Ambitions of the democratic
party he was a human being the facts of
his life matter including how he died
to this day media accounts describe
siknic as someone who was quote slain on
January 6th the video we reviewed proves
that is a lie here is surveillance
footage of sicknick walking in the
capital after he was supposedly murdered
by the mob outside by all appearances
sicknic is healthy and vigorous he's
wearing a helmet so it's hard to imagine
he was killed by a head injury
whatever happened to Brian sicknick was
very obviously not the result of
violence he suffered at the entrance to
the capital this tape overturns the
single most powerful and politically
useful eye the Democrats have told us
about January 6th and it was indeed a
lie the January 6 committee knew
perfectly well that Brian sicknick was
walking normally through the capitol
after he was supposedly murdered by
Trump supporters and they know that
because they saw this tape we can be
sure because the footage contains an
electronic bookmark that is still
archived in the capital's computer
system
that means that investigators working
for the Democratic party reviewed this
tape they saw it but they refused to
release the tape to the public why
because this tape would shatter the
fraud they were perpetrating on the
country because hiding the truth served
their political interest they lied about
the police officer they claimed to
Revere if they were willing to do that
then their dishonesty knew no limits
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight